so speaking of the poetry of human
experience you mentioned the images of
the black holes how did it make you feel
a few years ago when that first image
came out it's truly amazing
a sense of
well i guess the feeling was
both amazing and and there's a little
sense of um
jealousy is not quite the right word but
a sense of
longing yeah i think that's a better
word because
here's a subject that started with
einstein back in 1915 writes down the
equations of the general theory of
relativity
and then there are
scores of individuals over the decades
you know starting
with people like carl schwarzschild who
analyze the equation see the possibility
of black holes people develop these
ideas john wheeler all these greats of
physics
it's still a hypothetical subject it
gets closer to reality through
observations of the center of our galaxy
stars whipping around in a manner that
could only really be explained by there
being a black hole in the center of our
galaxy but it was still indirect
to actually have a direct image
that you can look at
what a beautiful arc narrative arc from
the theoretical to the absolutely
established and that's what we hope will
happen with other areas for instance
string theory right i mean
holy mathematical subject at the outset
and still pretty much a holy
mathematical subject today
yeah do we long
for that image where we can look at it
and say
string it's real you know i mean
how thrilling how thrilling to be part
of that journey to be part of that that
step that moves things from the abstract
to the concrete
yeah uh so like the image of the dna the
early images of the dna for example uh
but there is something especially so the
problem with strings
is they're tiny so it's harder to take a
picture i in in in the following sense
when you think of a black hole i mean
you have a swirl of i guess what is i i
don't even know it's dust to go whatever
light creeding on to the uh event
horizon and then there's darkness yeah
center and you you just imagine so that
picture in particular i guess is of a
gigantic black hole so
you just i mean it's 10 billion billion
billions of times the mass of the sun
yeah so it's both exciting and
terrifying i mean i don't i don't know
where you fall on the spectrum i think
it's exciting at first like the longer i
think about it every time i think about
it the more terrifying it becomes so it
always starts exciting
and then it goes to terrifying and both
are
feelings very human feelings that i
appreciate
it's like terrified aw
somehow it's still beautiful that's a
good way of saying it i think i kind of
share that that reaction because there
is a way in which
when you work on this subject like all
the time
i teach it i teach about black holes
write the equations on the blackboard
the ideas
reside
in a very cognitive
i don't know mathematical portion of the
brain or at least for me
and it's only when you like sit down and
it's quiet and you start to contemplate
wait wait wait this is just like a
mathematical game
there are these monsters out there now i
don't not in it in a sense of i fear for
my life but it's
a sense of
how extraordinary is this universe and
so it is breathtaking how powerful
nature is yeah how stupendously powerful
nature is um and so there is
a deep
sense of humility that i think this
instills if you really allow the ideas
to sink in
you